don't hold your breath that delightful
Chemistry Between the stars of only
murders in the building appears to be
just as electric behind the scenes
Selena Gomez spelled the beans it's
become all the rage for TV shows to get
their own podcasts often with stars of
the series in question to host them
they'll provide listeners with behind
the scenes fact toys about the making of
the show Bring on guests from in front
of or behind the camera to fill in any
gaps of knowledge and share all kinds of
onset stories that otherwise might not
make it to the public for fans of Disney
sitcoms of the 2000s Wizards of Waverly
Place got a podcast hosted by former
Stars Jennifer Stone who played Harper
on the show and David de Louise who
played Joey Russo the podcast only has a
few episodes so far but they dive into
many aspects of production and on
episode 4 they even got Alex Russo
herself pop culture sensation Selena
Gomez to stop by to chat she provided an
honest conversation about her time on
the series and even spoke about her
current gig on Hulu's only is in the
building more specifically she discussed
what it's like to work with comedy
Legend Steve Martin and Martin Short and
shed some light on their behavior away
from the cameras most actors are lucky
enough to get one iconic TV role in a
lifetime let alone two Selena Gomez is
now one of the lucky ones with only
murders in the building becoming a
streaming phenomenon in short order when
Gomez appeared on the Wizards of Waverly
pod podcast she spoke incredibly highly
of her co-stars she stated it's so
awesome working with Steve and Marty
um they're just I mean they're brilliant
in fact Gomez had heaps of great things
to say about the iconic comedy duo she
also lauded them for always being on
time which seems like odd praise they
are always on time kind
is that a big deal apparently it is
Anton to explain how being punctual is a
big deal for her because she makes an
effort to always be 10 minutes early
whenever she has to be somewhere Steve
Martin and Martin Shaw or sound like a
couple of stand-up guys as Gomez goes on
to say they're just lovely I have the
best time and they're constantly doing
bits it's hysterical I'm like now I know
all their bits so I'm kind of like oh
here's the punchline by the sound of it
Selena Gomez Hit It Off with Martin
shorts and Steve Martin immediately
proving that the chemistry viewers see
between her and the Beloved comedy duo
on only murders in the building is just
as prevalent behind the scenes though
there was no way to know that the three
of them would become a strong act
together Gomez knew from the moment the
opportunity to work with them was
presented to her that she had to take it
on she revealed as much during a June
2022 interview with deadline saying it
just felt like it was something I really
wanted to do they were all so lovely and
working with Steve and Marty would be a
dream Gomez adds that in the time senji
started working with short and Martin
she's learned a lot about how to punch
up her comedic timing saying actually
what I've learned from them is to be a
little more snarky I can tell that I
have a little more bite Marty would look
at me and say I did that wait are you
Mabel
totally Maple oh my god do we have fans
oh thank God we offend if you're hoping
to see Selena Gomez Martin shorts and
Steve Martin do what they do best on the
small screen again soon fret not only
murders in the building season 3 is
expected to reach Hulu in the near
future
[Music]
foreign